by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself for example communication
skills i tell the students that come
that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that if
they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person they
increase their value at least 50 percent
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and you have to be
able to get forth your ideas and that's
relatively easy i did it myself but it's
just hugely important and you if you
invest in yourself nobody can take it
away from you if i gave you a car and
it'd be the only car you get the rest of
your life you take care of it like you
can't believe any scratch you'd fix that
moment you read the owner's manual you
keep a garage and do all these things
and you get exactly one mind of one and
one body in this world and you can't
start taking care of it when you're 50
by that time you'll rush it out if you
haven't done anything so
just really make sure that you just
remember that you just got one mind and
body to get through life with and to do
the most with it
you know the most important thing is
it's really who you associate with you
want to associate with people that are
better than you are i mean basically
you'll go in the direction of the people
that you associate with and and you want
to have the right heroes you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
obviously you can't pick your parents
they're going to have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices as
you go down the line and you who you
want to copy and the most important for
most people in terms of that decision is
their spouse it's also important in
terms of a partner in business with the
partner in life is is the most important
you want to pick a spouse that's
better than you are biggest mistakes
people make
well they just don't realize that all
you have to do is just buy a
cross-section of america and they never
listen to people like me or read the
papers or do anything subsequently
they think they think that because you
can trade you should trade
you buy a farm you buy an apartment
house you can't resell it tomorrow and
you know the cost of
moving around or you now you get
something handed to your liquidity you
know which is instant you can sell
the cost of doing it are pennies you
know compared to other kinds of
investment activity so because they can
so easily move around they do move
around and moving around is not smart in
investing is business school worth it
depends on the person that much more
than it depends on the school i mean i i
wouldn't worry
some people are going to get a lot out
of advanced education and some people
are going to get very little and
i don't even think it's important that
every person go to college at all i mean
we have all kinds of jobs at 70 or so
thousand a year 80 000 a year that
college training is not abuse and i
actually was not keen on going to
college
myself yeah my dad kind of jollied me
into it he could get me to do anything
but i knew i could have a good time and
i liked investing and i didn't really
feel
i could read the books you know it's a
big commitment to take four years and
the cost involved and maybe the loans
involved and everything i think
depending on what your interests are in
life i don't think it's for everybody i
think it's for a lot of people but there
ought to be a reason you're going and i
didn't really see much reason you have a
pretty cool morning routine
regarding what you have for breakfast
and how prosperous what is that
i eat exactly what i like to eat if if i
liked it on my sixth birthday and my
sixth birthday party when we had hot
dogs and hamburgers and coke and ice
cream with chocolate i still like it and
i don't care about anything subsequently
i discovered it all by the time i was
six
and if if somebody offered me a deal
when i was 20 and said you're going to
live one year longer you know instead of
living to 88 you'll live 89 or whatever
it may be if you eat nothing but
broccoli and brussels sprouts and onions
and all these things and i i just said
i'll you know take the last year off it
probably won't be that good anyway you
know so
i eat what i like to eat warren how
would you define true success well i've
said many times that if you get to be
65 or 70 and later and and the people
that you want to have love you actually
do love you you're a success i've never
seen anybody that reaches that age i
mean i'm not talking about somebody
that's in extreme poverty or pain or
something but i've never seen anybody
that if they have a lot of people that
love them that
is other than happy and i've seen some
very very wealthy people that they give
testimonial dinners too and name schools
after and everything nobody nobody loves
them
[Music]